[Music]
this is the Honda Moto compacto a
reenvisioning of the original Moto compo
from the 1980s except this is all
electric and it's also designed like a
[Music]
suitcase you can essentially fold it all
down and there's a gra handle you can
use to pick it up and take it into a
train or a shop the downside is it is
about 41 lb so it's not something you
want to carry for a long time that might
be okay though because this is a last
milest scooter that's intended to take
you that extra bit of distance used in
conjunction with other modes of public
transportation the max range is about 12
Mi someone like me who's 6'4 will
probably see half that but it can go up
to 15 mph the seat is pretty comfy and I
didn't have any trouble reaching the
footrests you'll want to avoid potholes
though there's some dampening on the
tires but it's not going to Faire too
well over large bumps on the road it's
available only in the US at the moment
for $9.95